[Applause]  the hawks and the sixers game  seventh from philadelphia  quite a performance by police  yesterday had a huge gain off the bench  for the sixes  the crowd continues to count  on us count they are and count  loud as we all could hear that giannis  his struggles well documented shooting a  air ball on this free throw the crowd  feels like  it was their doing  milwaukee just five for 16 from the  field in the second quarter there's the  count it's a quick count though i'd have  to say  [Applause]  and fanasis not as his brother  trying to hype up and honest this taking  place  the last time out you got to appreciate  brotherly love reminds me probably of  you hyping up steve and al before their  broadcast  well he hits one of two